an actor might be replaced in a
television series due to schedule
conflicts lackluster chemistry behind
the scenes politics or even death
forgotten or not there's drama behind
the curtain
it's New York City in the early 80s
Christine Cagney is a modern single
woman in a former fashion model raised
in a comfortable middle class home Mary
Beth Lacy is a no-nonsense working mom
from the neighborhood together they are
beat styling cops they Patrol the Mean
Streets of Midtown Manhattan while
fighting against institutional sexism in
their own ranks Cagney and Lacey had a
passionate fan base that twice shaped it
from cancellation these are women
inspector
Stars Tyne Daly and Sharon glass
dominated the lead actress Emmy category
for the entire six-year run of the
series but Gless wasn't the first
actress cast as Cagney or even the
second the series began with a TV movie
starring Daley and mash star Loretta
Swit when sweat was unavailable for the
show Meg Foster was cast in her place
but after six episodes Gless took over
the part in a wide-ranging 2008
interview series producer Barney
rosenswag revealed the reason for
Foster's departure was one of
compatibility her performance was too
similar to what Daley was creating as
Lacey he explained it became Lacy and
Lacy at the time of the recasting
however rosenswogg gave a much different
rationale when interviewed by TV Guide
the viewers found Foster not feminine
enough and that together she and Daly
read as lesbians and apparently
distasteful situation to viewers in
1982. if you have a problem if no one
else can help and if you can find them
maybe you can hire The A-Team Sogo is
the famous opening narration of the
A-Team super producer Stephen J kennel's
1980s action series about a quartet to
Vietnam Vets who work as mercenaries in
the Los Angeles underground taking the
kinds of suicide missions that no one
else is bold or crazy enough to accept
the series stars 60s leading man George
prepared as Hannibal Smith the leader of
the group Dwight Schultz says pilot
Howlin mad Murdock Rocky III breakout
Star Mr T is all B.A barakis ba stands
for bad attitude and Battlestar
Galactica star Dirk Benedict as Master
of Disguise Faceman pack for the first
time around face men had a different
face altogether in the show's pilot
episode Peck is played by Love Boat star
Tim Dunagan the issue with done again
appropriately enough was his face though
technically old enough to have served in
Vietnam it was decided that in dunagan's
own words he was too young and too tall
for the role Benedict who had apparently
been canal and co-creator Frank Lupo's
First Choice was cast and played the
part for the rest of the series
the Law and Order franchise is no
stranger to inventive solutions for
temporarily unavailable cast members Law
and Order Special Victims Unit premiered
in 1999 the first franchise spin-off the
series follows the dedicated detectives
of the sex crimes focused Special
Victims Unit and delves further into the
personal lives of its leads than the
original show ever does this is
especially true for Mariska hargate as
detective Olivia Benson and Christopher
Maloney as her volatile partner Elliot
Stabler in 2006 it was announced that
hargate was taking a short leave of
absence from the show to accommodate the
final months of her pregnancy interplace
the show brought in Connie Nielsen as
detective Danny back partnering her with
stabler for a six-episode run in the
middle of season 8. her character was
clearly meant to be temporary still some
fans weren't pleased by her presence in
a 2020 interview Nielsen said she still
gets Danny back hate mail
Tony shaloob's defective detective in
the comedy series monk was always
socially awkward with a touch of
obsessive-compulsive disorder various
flashbacks through the seasons and a
visit from his brother confirmed that
his conditions were always present
within him but the moment that turned
his life upside down to the point that
he had to leave the San Francisco police
department and hire a nurse to assist
him was his wife's death his wife Trudy
was murdered by Car Bomb monk begins
after Trudy's death but the mystery
surrounding it is the show's primary
ongoing story reaching from the first
episode all the way to the last in the
first two seasons Trudy played by
stalina rusich is represented by a few
silent flashbacks and photographs on
Monk's mantle starting with season 3's
flashback heavy episode Mr Monk in the
game show however Trudy has played in
flashbacks by Melora Hardin an actress
probably best known for playing Jan
Levinson in the office and I have to
thank you for that other thing too
well marrying me oh look
you're welcome
pardon would appear a few more times
most notably in the two-part series
finale where her murder is finally
solved oddly as the series went on the
props Department used photos of both
rusage and Harden interchangeably and
even sat them next to each other in
Monk's house
generational trauma is at the heart of
David Chase's Landmark series The
Sopranos the HBO mob drama that in many
ways revolutionized television opening
the medium up to a more mature
serialized mode of Storytelling Tony
Soprano is a New Jersey mob boss who is
profoundly depressed and dissatisfied
with his life in ways that he can't
articulate much of his trauma can be
traced back to his mother Olivia and
Uncle Junior as well as the ghost of his
father Johnny Boy beginning with Season
Two Tony's Wayward sister Janus arrives
on the scene she's dealt with her
tumultuous upbringing by moving West and
embracing New Age philosophies but can't
help but get drawn back into their life
Tony and Janice aren't the only soprano
siblings however there's one more a
little sister who got out and stayed out
Barbara played in a handful of episodes
by Nicole Burdette Barbara lives out of
town and is rarely involved with the
soprano family business the character is
absent from seasons 3 and 4 then returns
for 10 episodes in the show's last two
seasons this time played by Danielle de
Vecchio even with her increased presence
in the series final run Barbara was
never a major character and her role was
by far the smallest in the family
NBC's Hannibal based on the best-selling
novels by Thomas Harris was unlike any
show on network television Baroque
gorgeous and gruesome series Creator
Brian Fuller crafted a bloody Thriller
for three seasons that was beautiful to
watch even if you were watching through
your fingers
this is the nightmare that followed him
out of his dreams
centered around haunted FBI profiler
Will Graham and a psychiatrist the
erudite Gourmet Hannibal Lecter the
series follows Graham's attempts to
catch various serial killers and protect
his own fragile sanity while Lecter
Works to keep Graham and his FBI boss
Jack Crawford from discovering that he
is a brutal cannibalistic killer himself
season 2 works and elements from
Harris's sequel Hannibal introducing
Meatpacking heiress Margo Verger and her
sadistic incestuous brother Mason played
by Michael Pitt Hannibal punishes Mason
for his abuse of Margo and for his
General impoliteness by drugging him and
forcing him to mutilate and eat his own
face in season 3 Mason returns for
Revenge paralyzed from the neck down and
horribly disfigured I would like you to
begin arrangements for Dr Hannibal
Lecter to be eaten alive
but the actor underneath the Prosthetics
is not pit but actor Joe Anderson as
Pitt declined to return to the role
after season two
premiering on NBC the same year as
Hannibal with a somewhat similar premise
was The Blacklist James Spader stars as
Raymond Reddington a master criminal
who's evaded capture for decades
Reddington turns himself into the FBI in
exchange for immunity promising to help
the bureau track down the world's most
dangerous criminals his Blacklist but of
course there's a catch Readington will
only work with rookie profiler Elizabeth
Keane while the series has a case of the
weak structure with red and Keen
bringing down one illegal operation or
another the central mystery of
readington's true identity and his
connection to Liz power the show through
10 high Intrigue Seasons a major clue to
the mystery of both red and Liz's
backgrounds dropped with the
introduction of Brian dennehy's
character Dominic Wilkerson in season
three as a former KGB agent posing as a
retired systems analyst Dom is a Long
messy history with red one that somehow
intersects with Liz's own background
after a handful of appearances Through
The Years Don becomes integral to the
show's ongoing storyline in season seven
but producers were thrown a tragic
curveball when Dennehy passed away in
April 2020 rather then rework the
upcoming season scripts the powers at B
decided to recast the role with actor
Ron Reigns who played Dom for three
episodes in season 8.
sometimes the show recasts a role due to
the death of an actor but other times
it's due to the death of the show itself
that was the case with all rise the CBS
courtroom drama that premiered in 2019
in which Simone Mystic starred as Lola
Carmichael a former prosecutor turned
Los Angeles County's newest judge
and in court before I know this works do
you think you know but you don't not yet
series followed the ins and outs of her
daily caseload as well as the lives of
the men and women who worked at the
courthouse for fellow judges her old
prosecutor colleagues clerks bailiffs
reporters and more Lola's husband FBI
agent Robin Taylor was played for the
first two seasons by Todd Williams the
show was canceled by CBS in May 2021.
several months later however it was
saved from Oblivion by the Oprah Winfrey
Network and a third and final season
aired on own in 2022 instead of asking
the cop why I was being zip tied you
asked me what I did wrong season 3 took
place a year after the events of season
two where saw Lola have a baby and lose
her judgeship after defending an
innocent woman from arrest most of the
original cast returned for the final
season with the exception of Williams
who had booked the Amazon young adult
series Panic as a result actor Christian
Keyes took over as Robin for season
three
each season of the Breaking Bad prequel
Better Call Saul begins with an
enigmatic black and white sequence
following the gray paranoid life of
Jimmy McGill formerly known as New
Mexico criminal lawyer salt Goodman now
living as Cinnabon manager Gene takovic
after the explosive events of the final
season of Breaking Bad starting in
season three however those opening
scenes coalesce into an ongoing story as
a panic attack puts Gene in the hospital
season 4 begins with Gene's cab ride
back from the hospital where his driver
has an Albuquerque Isotopes decal on his
mirror and keeps shooting glances at his
passenger season 5 reveals that the
driver Jeff played by Don Harvey does
indeed recognize Gene as Saul but his
motivations remain unclear the sixth and
final season foregoes the black and
white scenes until the final three
episodes where Gene decides not to run
again but to confront Jeff and
neutralize him via an old-fashioned slip
and Jimmy con game for these final
episodes however Harvey was not
available due to his commitment to the
HBO series we own the city Pat Healy
stepped into the role Jeffy this is Mr
takovic call me Gene Harvey's original
take out a hint of menace while Heelys
was more of a sad sack dibor C living
with his mother and desperate for a
taste of assault Goodman lifestyle
Law and Order and its spin-offs have had
no shortage of cast turnover over the
decade since its 1990 Premiere part of
this is baked into the premise of the
show detectives and attorneys come in
and out on a regular basis and the
departures are explained by transfer
retirement arrest or even death the
areas of the show come to be defined by
who's running the two separate but
equally important groups in the criminal
justice system seasons four through six
Encompass Jill Hennessey's turn as
assistant district attorney Claire
Kincaid a search warrant with this
but you can't be serious toward the end
of Hennessey's run on the show she
appeared in character as Kincaid on a
1996 episode of homicide life on the
street while it's not exactly a Law and
Order spin-off it existed in the same
television universe and occasionally
shared characters most memorably Richard
Belzer's detective John Munch filming
homicide on location in Baltimore
however meant that Hennessey missed a
few days of filming the season six Law
and Order episode Corpus delicti luckily
she had a novel solution to this problem
her identical twin sister Jacqueline
could step in his Kincaid for a few
background courtroom shots